looking back at the 19th century it's
possible to say that the extreme
popularity of serial novel the novel
released in installments over time was
inevitable in London changing economics
were creating the perfect conditions for
this to happen
thousands of people were moving into the
city literacy among the lower and middle
classes was increasing and new printing
and distribution technologies were
coming into their own but the magic that
made cereal such a huge success wasn't
only in the conditions of the times and
publishers like Chapman & Hall knew that
it was also in the genius of upstarts
like the one they chose a young writer
named Charles Dickens Chapman & Hall
commissioned Dickens to write a few
sporting stories to be released with
sketches done by the artists Richard
Seymour altogether the project was
called the posthumous papers of The
Pickwick Club or The Pickwick Papers for
short
the first part was horrendous failure
only 400 copies were sold after the
second part seymour committed suicide
and had to be replaced it wasn't until
the fifth installment when Dickens
introduced a funny working class
character named sam Weller that the
project struck gold Weller was a massive
hit and after the insistence of the
readership the character was expanded
throughout the rest of the series
launching its sales from 400 to 40,000
for installment thanks to Dickens thanks
to publishers like Chapman and Hall
thanks to new printing presses and
liberal education and railways the
serial novel dominated the world of
literature for the next 60 years and
though most novels these days aren't
published like The Pickwick Papers were
the genre of serialization and it is a
genre has proven to be remarkably strong
flourishing and almost every
storytelling medium and this is no
accident as Jennifer Hayward notes in
her incredible book consuming pleasures
the cereal is sort of the perfect forum
for capitalism it captures readers with
the promise of more constantly delaying
gratification and this makes it very
commercially effective and for the same
reasons for its appeal to mass-market
consumer cereals have been castigated by
critics
from the jump before Dickens became a
household name
high society reviewers raked his work
through the mud and the same kind of
treatment has been meted out on every
new incarnation of the cereal whether
it's comics the cereal films of the 40's
pulp novels soap operas or the endless
sequels of Hollywood blockbusters
somewhere in space this may all be
happening right now
star wars holds I think an interesting
place in the history of the cereal a
history that began with Dickens and like
Dickens George Lucas is a special kind
of visionary going against the grain of
gritty realistic films that dominated
the 1970s Lucas devised a sweeping space
adventure epic with broad themes
influenced by the first generation of
film cereal like Flash Gordon and he was
shrewd enough to understand the
advantages of serialization when it came
up to doing the contract for the film I
knew that what I really had to do was to
protect the unwritten part the other two
parts of the script the truth is that
all cereals share a group of common
features and characteristics going all
the way back to the pic with papers like
Dickens stories and comic book universes
and star wars serials tend to feature
giant casts of characters and those
characters tend to resemble the mass
public that consumes them over time and
often far too slowly cereals trend
toward diversity and because of the
massive casts cereals also have lots of
subplots and the main plots often
feature surprising reversals and twists
and revelations that keep the audience
reaching for the next installment
now this can make for cliche and
hackneyed storytelling like in the case
of soap operas which reconstructed the
form to the point of delaying all
conclusions infinitely but even soap
operas demonstrate what is probably the
two most important features of serials
the creation of interpretive communities
and their sensitivity to the audience's
desires a lot of the criticism of
Dickens work centered around its
addictive quality that the books took
their readers out of everyday life
the truth was the opposite cereals
created social bonds around the content
in question acting in this case against
the alienating effects of capitalism and
the Industrial Revolution
what's more within this space even the
lower classes at a forum for engaging in
political discourse discussing what you
thought about Bleak House or Oliver
Twist was a way of debating social norms
when the force awakens came out last
year its emphasis on practical effects
and tactile imagery was as much a result
of the audience's referendum on the
prequel films as the expansion of the
sam Weller character was for Dickens in
The Pickwick Papers but this relaunch of
the Star Wars serials strikes me as
something new Under the Sun like soap
operas it's promising to be endless like
the Marvel film franchise it's promising
to be connected and intertwined but
unlike most of the comic films so many
of the stories and characters have yet
to be written and it's going to be the
first film serial in which subplots
are going to be told as dedicated
features in their own run in the
anthology series this means opportunity
for audiences the so-called new golden
age of TV is almost exclusively down to
serialize shows that up their game
because that's what audiences demanded
the new Star Wars franchise is primed to
explode in a thousand directions and
right now at the beginning is when we
can help to write the rules for what
kind of serials that we want to see a
new incarnation of serialization is here
for film 180 years after The Pickwick
Papers were first published that's a
long history so why not mine it for all
the best qualities of this resilient and
perceptive shot
hey everybody thanks for watching I
really want to recommend Jennifer
Hayward's book consuming pleasures if
you want to know more about the history
of serialization not just in novels but
in comics and soap operas it is required
reading I loved it so much so I'll put a
link in the description below also thank
you to Squarespace for sponsoring this
video if you don't know Squarespace
helps you make really sleek intuitive
websites without having to know coding
they do all the work for you really you
can get a free domain name if you sign
up for a year and if you go to
Squarespace comm and use the offer code
nerdwriter
you can get 10% off your first purchase
so thank you so much I'll see you guys
next Wednesday Squarespace you should